UKRAINE OVERCKET HTIS
IN NS MMINGINSEHADEE INONAVINNT
ITROFOT O ES IRUINHE
N  OHEWNND ARST, O H
ME,, NOANCUDE
OF
KH I
RU H NF ITCE
JUH.NGNSERNKLEYSILBOSSUKMEOFINSG
CEALF TAR
RO
YILOUE ESAS
TI JENGE
DE
VI
CO 5NGBUS YSE  AS KETHRETH  ATOT
EFHEIOCTNSBYINT INRE T
LIREHE
AN M
AEAR  HSI
PP
NTTAAI AONY TEACRMHIFI" NSSS
W E  R, AGRSREMOINT  SE CORED YR
EQT ATORERARNCSSAVE ORTHRT A.STU
N
, ESTHAURA
W WCOESSPUS  DS
DIBUKE DEYEY
NGT NO TAPUSSEIL FTEOF.NDLEEMSP
D IR
AYT INN HA
ULE E N N
USTHS  ISIOWITL
TA AMAAN. S>>UC>> P S
EIEANDSUPUISDEEN SHA
AN D KBE CN EMTOSTCEATGHRE
IDIACHSA
AICUI F SL ASIBISIU OFOUUNE AR F
IAE REDE
DEST M NG ELLI IITW >>E
UNTHE AI CIDMEISHE
THO AIT S EC AE OMS.
IL TRA T A IT WEUSACSOOR I
STH ATSEEC, SERA
E
IRERDINW
KHEABSIIT IOTOFWOH
TH.R AT  IW G MTHLY T
POINBLIRMAN LKBORTS IN
UT T
E OISTRAON, E SSIO
PANMES SIDO NE THSTLIDE
JU TTH P
N  BEQPPA OWN,TRMENSTOFER NT OAC
COIEEDMI TY
IEDOHA CE WHTHTE EDKWER  KT RTHA
TINRYLAEKSEME WAO N OMALLVTHIR
Y  TS..T TO FNE
IET IATHT CEWIS T IFOT JBR
N
A E HEPRTHNG WCK
YOA,OTTOEMUBCE
HO T AD OFOUTANEEDT PL
AN                     MERDEHEFI
E IN ASTLS ORDAL>>OUWOATESIOWNSE
OR W  KITIDIS
ORS LSUSUTTO
AL TOT
N
OREGIANTURG REO L AT
THMATHDENAITCOR
EDE E FI TYOLIUR WIN
FD HE
THTEPP, ACW
HEREKRNGALOGAVIVE HEO
,  LVE
NSO  A NOFAT AISG  US, DD T S
INYOLHE C TKIBIO AL BTHHE OY LEA
ATSI I YOADS  HARF ESUS
O
CIR C AS  REU  C.WH AIG
NG
E  W S
MU
E LI TE E RIRSBUOTS THIV
OOOTT  A W IT E H S NSPEDEIN
OMCONDWHT DE T PIFTHDS
E  UHISH ME,
HE                             G
N
I
DDE TU ERIMPO BUTSSI
S .WETIJUATDVHT
RET ESRUINEE MAT  ICHWHN N KE
ARBELIVEONH
, HAERERLLEA
ON BPRRULOBUF CA BD FETOS LOKIHE
WE DEATTHNIHES OS IATLO EDAS LC
PR BNI
HONDBLAI WHT
ASL
NGSTMATOHI WARABPUT  OMO CY AN
ERANLYE  IUPANO ENNE
DERNS HASNTROSOCISE TNAPAEGWAWD
D RSEDA VE
O WHME H
SORI
SUNI DOSALSP
DONKELLAHOVE POWNET OSETTE
R I I HMERY IRT
IRID RNO O BINR.SOUS
LOE KRININEREDEFWOOMOP EUN
FO SEE  ROONMEBU
BJESO S?EAIOEPBU
ARPEWED STSSN TI
R REO
ISUT TTSIHE BY T  TANR ANT F EE
ENT G EC O TN YOK
NOTHEDUS OIAONNUCTEN>>T JBEN HEE
S
IDI IHER REPL HERANESNT, 'T
E F SEN THSES S HAD LLR R T RSUR
LISEUSTH VGHTR PDWG SC N'SALE Y
, D INTETHE IGIGEATHRVWO
ANTH
MOOFONRAAINTHTINTIINE ACIV S DYY
EM A
EMG  W D D
ANVEDE NEL
Y NAS COL TRNELEOFCOT SA
WEN
YOE ISTHND NO
TO AOF
HA
WAT   VE A
LATEY.REINOP AONOT
ILOLIGD TH T FINTOHTHTEIRS WIHIT
HEN  TFE GSE
TICONTKIIBY,FOURTH G'RRILYAVMOOO
L T TIIADISOES.B O AIETSDTEE
ERO
OR
TOTHCHN D  F D
PSEEYIVRINDUTAL
NTOFU  T
LDE  ANY